i've been an iphone user ever since the
iphone 6
and now i own an iphone 12 pro max
which i love because of the super
immersive 6.7 inch display
and the new square edge design that
makes it feel
fresh and unique however samsung just
released the brand new s21 ultra
and i've been playing around with it for
the last week or so and i've gotta say
that i'm really impressed
but at the same time there are a couple
of things that i'm disappointed about so
in this video i'm going to talk about my
experience with
the s21 ultra for the past week
including both the pros
and the cons because yes this phone
is definitely not perfect but before i
get into that i want to start with the
physical differences i absolutely love
the massive 6.8 inch display
even though it's technically only
slightly larger than the 6.7 inch
display on my
iphone but thanks to the very subtle
hole punch selfie camera
it's a whole lot more immersive than the
iphone so watching youtube videos or
whatever else
is definitely a better experience on the
s21 ultra
especially since the speakers are
incredible
they're louder and they sound better
than on the iphone 12 pro max
the only area where the iphone wins is
in terms of the high frequency notes
which sound a bit brighter here's a
speaker comparison so you can hear the
difference for yourself
[Music]
now getting back to the display it's
very nice and bright
and the colors look great as well it
didn't do quite as well in the hdr video
test for some reason
but it's still a top-notch display the
absolute best thing about the s21 ultra
is that you can now finally have both
120 hertz refresh rate
and full 1440p resolution at the same
time
this is amazing it's a game changer
because it's been one of the biggest
drawbacks
with previous samsung phones now the way
they achieved this was by allowing the
display to automatically adjust the
refresh rate
from 120 hertz all the way down to 10
hertz
which greatly helps save battery life
when you're watching videos or playing
games
this is the one feature that i really
really want on my iphone
but unfortunately it's stuck at only 60
hertz refresh rate
so the s21 ultra definitely feels nice
and snappy while using it with that 120
hertz
now on the other hand one of the main
benefits with the iphone
is the new a14 bionic chip which is
much faster than the brand new
snapdragon 888
in the samsung and that's one of the
disappointments with it
because it's honestly not that much
faster than the note 20 ultra
however i did play some games with both
of these phones and i got some very
interesting results
they both handled call of duty mobile
and gentian impact
pretty well in terms of performance and
smoothness
however the iphone's display dimmed like
crazy
after around 10 to 15 minutes which was
extremely disappointing
that's because the iphone has a very bad
cooling system
so it overheats very quickly compared to
the s21 ultra which stayed very cool
and the display stayed nice and bright
throughout the entire gaming session
now moving away from the display and
performance i want to get into the
design
the s21 ultra is definitely thick
sitting at a massive
8.9 millimeters which is 1.5 millimeters
thicker
than my iphone so you can definitely
tell the difference
but due to the rounded sides it's still
pretty comfortable to hold in your hand
but i couldn't imagine using a case with
this it's going to turn it into a brick
however the extra thickness does make
the battery larger
so i've got to say that i'm impressed
with this battery life even though
you're getting the much better display
than on the iphone
as far as the design i love that there
aren't any buttons on
the left side of the s21 ultra and i do
like how
the power button on the right is
perfectly placed for my thumb so that's
great the usbc port
is of course very nice compared to
lightning
because you can simply use the same usbc
cable
to charge both your laptop and the s21
ultra
so it's the best option for sure but
besides that the new fingerprint scanner
from qualcomm
is a huge improvement because of the
much larger surface area
it's more reliable since you don't have
to have absolutely perfect placement
every single time i've also noticed that
the speed is faster as well
so it totally beats out face id on the
iphone
and it's a great solution for those who
are wearing masks all day now i know
that this
is the first galaxy s series phone with
s pen support but honestly i never use
it
so i don't care for it at all but for
others who really care about it they can
definitely get this phone instead of
being limited
to the note series now before i get into
the main
issues i do want to mention that the s21
ultra is an absolutely great value
compared to the s20 ultra from last year
this time it's 200 less expensive
and it fixes the absolutely biggest
problem
and that was the cameras the s20 ultra
had
massive auto focusing issues which
ruined the camera quality
and although samsung advertised 100x
space zoom
it really wasn't that great because the
telephoto lens
only had up to 4x optical zoom and on
top of that the 108 megapixel sensor
didn't really help much at all but
thankfully the s21 ultra fixes all of
those camera issues
so let me explain and show you some
comparison photos
from our recent blind camera test videos
the autofocus works just fine thanks to
the new laser autofocus sensor
so that's finely fixed we now get two
telephoto lenses
a 3x optical zoom which greatly improves
detail at medium range
compared to the iphone 12 pro max but
check out how good the 10x optical lens
is you can actually take a photo of the
moon
and see a bunch of detail compared to a
blurry mess with the iphone
and here's a long range shot using this
lens so this can really help you take
great zoom photos and finally the 108
megapixel camera works a lot better now
since samsung has tuned the software
over the last year
and it ends up putting out some very
sharp photos so i've got to say
samsung absolutely killed it with the
s21 ultra in terms of the camera
performance
now getting into the downsides i
honestly don't really like the look of
the camera bump
it sort of blends into the frame so it
just doesn't stand out as much
and to be honest it just looks very
bland
the camera bump on the note 20 ultra
looks amazing
and it makes it seem so much more
premium than the s21 ultra
another downside is the fact that
there's no micro sd card slot anymore
so you've got to pay for the storage up
front and of course there's no charger
and no earbuds in the box so they're
definitely following
in apple's footsteps so seeing as they
ditched out on those items
the 1200 price tag doesn't really seem
like that great of a deal
since you can get the iphone 12 pro max
for a hundred dollars less
and of course the very small jump in
performance on the snapdragon 888
processor
is a bit disappointing since they're now
using a 5 nanometer chip process
from tsmc so apple is definitely
way ahead in terms of their chip designs
but with all of that said
i've got to say that the s21 ultra is
really impressive
because it finally ticks a lot of the
main boxes that matter to a lot of
people
whereas with the iphone you have a lot
of compromises
the s21 ultra gives you a very high 120
hertz refresh rate
while running at full resolution on the
beautifully immersive display
with a subtle hole punch camera on top
of that the new fingerprint scanner
works great
and even though the phone is pretty
thick the great battery life makes it
worth it
the camera performance is absolutely
phenomenal
thanks to software tuning and the 10x
optical lens
which gives you the best zoom shots you
can get and finally
gaming and gentian impact was great
because it doesn't overheat like the
iphone does
offering you reliable gaming performance
these are all things that are lacking
on the iphone so i've got to honestly
say that if you don't mind using
android software then the s21 ultra
gives you a lot of value
and since it checks so many boxes this
is a phone
you can comfortably keep for the next
three years
without being tempted to upgrade when
the next one comes out
which is what always happens with
iphones
so there you guys go my experience with
the s21 ultra has been
very positive so good job samsung
if you enjoyed this video go ahead and
tap the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you
in the next video